going back to when you were three yeah I
want to hear about what it was that
where you knew that you were meant to be
a writer what was it you were doing at
three that's fascinating
my mother was northen and she had a
photographic memory and she would work
out these stories of her orphanage
experience and I really believed that
that we were all meant to just remember
everything and to tell these stories to
other people and so I would remember
like I would go back and remember what
was I doing a year ago in school what
was i doing a week ago in school or who
has said to me at what time you know
what was I what was I saying or doing
and I and I started sort of telling
myself my own story and thinking in the
future I will tell people these stories
that I'm thinking myself as a child and
then I loved I loved reading and I loved
imagining other worlds and and putting
myself in other worlds and so that was
just always and then I became the
restorer a teller I became fascinated by
why stories affect us why am i in terms
of endearment and I'm just weeping what
how how is it that something I'm seeing
from people I don't know is making me
cry and and so I just became really
fascinated at that at the mechanics of
creating motion and creating motion and
stories so when you say overthinking and
sort of it is it almost like it has its
roots in meditation where you're turning
off the mind in some sense you are and
so this process that I've developed
because because you need guideposts
right and it's kind of the way I think
about it is like this if you're telling
a story you need to know the genre you
need to know what you want to create
what feeling you want to generate and
that genre that destination is like
saying I want to go to Phoenix right
that's your guideposts going to Phoenix
I'm telling a love story
now how you get to Phoenix could have a
number of different ways and so what you
have to think about is well along this
route where do I want to stop where are
my scenes
well maybe Palm Springs maybe Joshua
Tree you may want to take a big detour
down to Baja right you can do that but
you know you're getting to Phoenix and
so the way I think about story is to
give you those guideposts of the act
structure the end of the end of the
first act the midpoint end of the second
act the climax so those are guideposts
like saying I'm gonna hit Palm Springs
and Joshua Tree and Baja and then and
and you can create the visuals you can
create the that the you can create the
scenes around those places because you
know you got to get there but once you
know those guideposts you know there's a
journey to those places and you can
relax in knowing that the that the
journey has an organic flow and you
don't have to force it and you can relax
and let your your meditative mind take
over how you get there because you know
you're gonna stop in Palm Springs and
have a wonderful experience you know
you're gonna stop in Joshua Tree and
have a wonderful experience and then you
ultimately you'll get to Phoenix which
is your climax and you you can imagine
what's gonna happen there so it's it's
kind of releasing your mind from needing
to know how you get there and instead
just imagining wonderful destinations
along the journey I don't know if that's
clear at all but I'm trying to think of
another way to say it you when you when
you're when you're looking to tell a
story there's an emotion that you want
to create there's two skills to learn
one is the actual that the means of
generating emotion whether it's
generating how somebody's going to cry
in a love story or how to create
suspense in a thriller and then there's
the story you want to tell and that
story can be very organic it can be
really who you are and the tools of
genre and the tools of these of
storytelling allow you to take the
internal you and make it into something
that
and an audience will want to see but you
don't have to control it to get there it
you can you can do it in a more organic
way
you